what is our plants could sense the
toxicity levels in the soil and express
that toxicity through the color of this
leaf one of those plants could also
remove those toxins from the soil
instead what if those plants grew their
own packaging or we're designed to only
be harvested by their owners own
patented machines what happened when
biological design is driven by the
motivations of mass-produced commodities
what kind of world would that be my name
is Annie and I'm a designer and
researcher at MIT VD lab where I'm part
of a relatively new and unique group
called design fiction where we're wedged
somewhere between science fiction and
science fact and at MIT I'm lucky enough
to rub shoulders with scientists
studying all kinds of cutting-edge
fields like synthetic neurobiology
artificial intelligence artificial eyes
and everything in between and across
campus there's truly brilliant
scientists asking questions like how can
I make the world a better place and part
of what my group likes to ask is what is
better what is better for you for me for
a white women a gay man a veteran a
child with a prosthetic technology is
never neutral it frames a reality and
reflects a context can you imagine what
it would say about the work-life balance
at your office of these were standard
issue on the first day I believe it's
the role of artists and designers to
raise critical questions art is how you
can see and feel the future and today is
an exciting time to be a designer for
all the new tools becoming accessible
for instance synthetic biology seeks to
write biology as a design problem and
through these developments my lab asks
what are the roles and responsibilities
of a artists designer scientist or
businessman what are the implications of
synthetic biology genetic engineering
and how are they shaping our notions of
what it means to be a human what are the
implications of this
society on evolution and what are the
stakes in this game my own speculative
design research at the current moment
plays with synthetic biology but for
more emotionally driven output I'm
obsessed with olfaction as a design
space and this project started with this
idea of what if you could take a smell
selfie a selfie what if you could take
your own natural body odor and send it
to a lover funny enough I found that
this is a 19th century Austrian
tradition where couples in courtship
would keep a slice of apple crammed
under their armpit
during dances and at the end of the
evening the girl would give the guy she
most fancied her youth fruit and if he
the feeling was mutual he would wolf
down at CG Apple famously Napoleon wrote
many love letters to Josephine but
perhaps amongst the most memorable is
this brief and urgent note home in three
days don't face both Napoleon Josephine
adored violets Josephine more viola
scented perfume carried violets on their
wedding day and the point sent her
bouquet of violets every year on their
anniversary when Joseph being passed
away he planted violets at her grave and
just before his exile he went back to
that tomb site pick some of those
flowers and tuned them in a locket and
wore them until the day he died and I
found this so moving I thought could I
engineer that violet to smell just like
Josephine what is for the rest of
eternity when you went to visit her site
you could smell Josephine just as
Napoleon loved her could we engineer new
ways of mourning new rituals for
remembering after all we've engineered
transgenic crops to be maximized for
profit crops that stand up to transport
crops that have a long shelf life crops
that taste sugary sweets but resist
pests sometimes at the expense of
nutritional value can we harness these
same technologies for an emotionally
sensitive output so currently in my lab
I'm researching questions like what
makes a human smell like a human and it
turns out it's fairly complicated
factors such as your diet your
medications your lifestyle all factored
into the way you smell
and I found that our sweat is mostly
odorless but it's our bacteria and
microbiome that's responsible for your
smells your mood your identity and so
much beyond and there's all kind of
molecules that you admit but which we
only perceive subconsciously so I've
been cataloguing and collecting bacteria
from different sites of my body after
talking to a scientist we thought maybe
the perfect concoction of an e is like
10% collarbone 30% underarm 40% bikini
line and so forth and occasionally I let
researchers from other labs take a sniff
of my samples and something interesting
to hear how smell of the body is
perceived outside of the context of the
body I've gotten feedback such as smells
like flowers like chicken like corn
flakes like beef carne bears at the same
time I cultivate a set of carnivorous
plants for their ability to emit flesh
like odors to attract prey in an attempt
to kind of create this symbiotic
relationship between my bacteria and
this organism and as it so happens I'm
at MIT and I'm at a bar and I was
talking to a scientist who happens to be
a chemist and a plant scientist is
telling him about my project and he was
like well this sounds a lot like botany
for a lonely woman
I'm perturbed I said okay I challenge
them can you how can we engineer a plant
that can love me back and for some
reason he was like sure why not so we
started with can we get a plant to grow
towards me like I was the Sun and so
we're looking at mechanisms and plans
such as phototropism which causes the
plant to took grow toward the Sun by
producing hormones like oxygen which
causes cell elongation on the shady side
and right now I'm creating a set of
lipsticks that are infused with these
chemicals that allow me to interact with
the plant on its own chemical signatures
let's fix that cause plants to grow
where I kiss it plant stuff blossoms
where I kiss the bloom and through these
projects I'm asking questions like how
do we define nature how do we define
nature when we can re-engineer its
properties and when should we do it
should we do it for
profit for utility can we do it for
emotional ends can biotechnology be used
to create work as moving as music what
are the thresholds between science and
its ability to shape our emotional
landscape it's a famous design mantra
that form follows function
well now wedge somewhere between science
design and art I get to ask what a
fiction informs back what kind of our
indie lab would that look like and what
kind of questions would we ask together
we often look to technology as the
answer but as an artist and designer I
like to ask but what is the question
thank you